(bright music)
- Did you have fun tonight
with your other friends?
You better tell me no.
You better tell me no!
- Listen, it was just dinner
in the theater district.
Let's go to Times
Square, for dinner.
- Gross.
You ever hear of the
heart of darkness?
You've like entered
the heart of darkness.
- Ever hear of it?
I live it every day.
(laughing)
- Will you look at my, like,
grandma lipstick on this J?
- It's good, oh, all
my lipstick came off,
'cause I...
There was like...
- Dude, check this out.
Oh, God! (yelling)
(yelling)
- Oh, my God, what's happening?
Are you watching this?
- [Ilana] Ow!
- Ilana, watch this.
(Ilana laughing)
(Abbi imitates monster)
(laughing)
- Okay, check this out.
Did you know that I'm
in my second trimester?
- What are you having?
- A girl.
- Ilana, is that my baby?
Is that what this
call's really about?
- You have really strong sperm
that fights through
birth control.
- Yes!
- Oh!
Oh my God, it's coming.
(moaning and yelling)
God!
Oh my God.
Look at her. (crying)
- Hold on, what is
all gooey all over it?
- [Ilana] Lube.
- When did you put
that all over her?
- [Ilana] Um, just before.
- Are you jerking off the head?
- No, you massage a baby's
head so it gets round,
'cause they're all squooshed
from your birth canal.
- How do you know?
- Dude, I studied to be a doula,
or, I quit, but I
started to study.
- Wait, Ilana, I have one.
Calling all the basic bitches.
There's a new announcement.
You're basic.
- Abbi!
Sh, you're gonna wake the baby.
(bright music)